the tax break to the rich slashing taxes
on the super-rich unfair they say the
Republican tax plan favors rich people
and that's especially wrong because the
super-rich greedily takes so much that
other Americans have less but is that
true my goal in life is to be the best
part of your day
Jim Caruso is rich he took over a
bankrupt brewery and made it successful
by creating a bunch of what I would
think were absurd new craft beers like
blood orange am at the end of the day
you can sit back and sip a beer and just
appreciate the beauty of life
Caruso now employs a hundred people his
company is worth more than 50 million
dollars thanks to Flying Dog brewery
he's now richer than most millionaires
and billionaires people on the Left say
it's unfair you will have unequal
outcomes and I would argue that it's
possible we all benefit from that for
example somebody decides that their
pursuit of happiness means being a
doctor they spend 12 years in school so
I have an excellent doctor to serve me
somebody else might want to be a
world-class tattoo artist these result
in different outcomes for people on
average the doctor will make more money
than the tattoo artist but some
Americans are a thousand times richer
than others the top 1% has earned 85% of
all new income the top fraction of
earners has just about half the essence
in this country this ticks people off
they view it as evil think about it this
way last year I saw that there were 1
billion apple devices actively being
used and last month I saw that Apple was
the first company to be worth eight
hundred billion dollars today Apple is
going to reinvent the phone that was
curious how much was Steve Jobs worth in
2011 when he passed away at too early of
an age ten billion dollars I did some
quick calculations rough math let's look
at those calculations Steve Jobs earn 10
billion dollars but Apple sold more than
2 billion devices
that means jobs collected about 5 bucks
for every device certainly your cell
phone is worth more to you than $5 it
must because you willingly paid several
hundred dollars for this I think Steve
might have been underpaid here the
feeling tends to be that somebody like
Steve Jobs took something away from
everybody else but what did Steve Jobs
take from us he had this idea wouldn't
it be great to have a thousand songs in
your pocket
one of the most massively important
tools for productivity and communication
in life so it's that zero-sum game
mentality that somehow people who create
stuff are taking it away from other
people and that's simply inaccurate it's
not a zero-sum game to creating stuff
that didn't exist before they are
creating stuff and unless they collude
with government they can get rich only
by making our lives better
you